do you think that the U.S provoked
Russia through its operations in Ukraine
I think what provoked Russia was our
failure to withdraw effectively from
Afghanistan and we were so feckless and
it was such that's not to criticize
anybody that was on the ground doing the
work that's not what I'm criticizing but
the the failure that was a debacle and I
think Putin looked at that I think when
they opened up the pilot Bureau archives
in like 50 years and they look at their
National Security Council notes they're
going to go like wow Putin saw that as
weakness in the United States and saw
that as a green light to go after we saw
it we saw it in Taiwan why did Russia go
into Ukraine
I have no idea